How to Train Your Dragon the hidden
world is hitting the big screen in late
February of 2019 its cast is ripe with
hilarious actors some of which might
surprise you so who's ready to get to
know them
now let's check out the cast of How to
Train Your Dragon the hidden world
[Music]
Craig Ferguson as Gobber Gobber the
belch is a blacksmith who's basically
considered as hiccups second father he's
a veteran warrior with a barbaric
attitude and we wouldn't change him for
the world actor Craig Ferguson voices
him and he's too busy for his own good
so who better than him to portray the
opinionated Gobber
Craig is originally from Scotland which
makes mastering gobber's thick accent a
breeze so how did the actor come up with
Gobber stone well might as well hear it
from the man himself you put your voice
in that character and I believe that I
can oh wow it talks a little bit higher
than me Craig Scottish accent is so on
point that he was also asked to voice
Lord Macintosh in the Disney movie brave
I present my ear and sire and he
absolutely nailed it
during an interview which was posted by
the same fantastic online YouTube
channel Craig explained how he feels
like he resembles his character Gobber
and here's what the comic had to say I
think was interesting is when I started
doing the voice I didn't look much like
him but now I do so how did this famous
writer and actor get the gig well he was
lured into it by a very compelling
argument while being interviewed by many
the movie guy Craig came clean about how
he landed the role she said we couldn't
be in this movie I said no and she said
Jerry butlers and I said okay now if
that isn't hilarious we don't know what
is f murray abraham as grimille every
movie needs a bad guy and this time
around actor s murray Abraham is willing
to tap into his evil side Murray's
voicing the big bad grimille in How to
Train Your Dragon the hidden world and
he's the worst antagonist this franchise
has yet to see he's determined to hunt
every last night fury there is and no
one not even hiccup can stand in his way
although Mary might play
dark and twisted character he's nothing
like grimille in real life while
interviewing on live with Kelly Marie
came clean about his real personality
and here's what the oscar-winning actor
had to say well it's I'm the nicest man
I know great although he might be a nice
guy he's used to auditioning for
villainous roles Murray's a master when
it comes to mimicking different accents
which is how he landed the role of Omar
in Scarface although hiccups village has
made peace with the Dragons grimille is
not about to join their ranks in fact he
wants nothing more than to eliminate
dragons for good he's described as the
darkest threat to the dragons and
Vikings alike and he made a promise to
hiccup that he intends to keep I
wouldn't destroy everything you know we
hope that hiccup and his pals will find
a way to destroy their enemy before he
hurts any more dragons america ferrera
as astrid astrid might have started as a
rough and tough character but she
eventually warmed up to hiccup and
became his girlfriend
this little Viking is brave and loyal
making her the ideal woman for hiccup
acclaimed actress America Ferrera voices
her and we couldn't have asked for a
better match America's character is
quick and efficient which is why she's
the one who came up with an appropriate
name for toothless's new girlfriend
[Music]
probably she's bright and sassy which
often leads hiccup to agree with her the
actress came clean about what compelled
her to audition for asteroids role in
the first place she's sort of the best
of her class she's the most promising
America is a big-time actress who's even
won a Golden Globe Award for her
performance in the hit TV series Ugly
Betty she's got a sweet voice that can
quickly turn to stone making her the
ideal match for Astrid this video was
posted by the screen slam YouTube
channel I mean chief what an honor what
you're searching for isn't out there
hiccup Christopher mintz-plasse as
Fishlegs if there's one friend hiccup
can always count on its Fishlegs this
burly character knows everything there
is to know about dragons Christopher
mintz-plasse is a name most of us know
very well his acclaimed doctor
genius when it comes to comedy and he
brings his unique flavor to Fishlegs
your small squeaky voice would be great
coming out of it while he had to find
out the hard way that his voice is on
the squeaky side that's never stopped
Christopher from landing some big-time
roles so which other movies does the
star partaken well he plays the one and
only foggle in the hit movie super bad
however his character in this film
prefers to go by another name hey so
what's it gonna be I am making love in
when it comes to getting into character
Chris doesn't waste any time here's a
clip of him going all-out while in the
studio survival Wendling although
everyone might think that Chris and
fishlegs look nothing alike the actor
would beg to differ Jay Baruchel as
hiccup hiccup always felt like he stuck
out like a sore thumb so he did what he
did best and continued to follow his
path despite going against everything
the Viking stood for hiccup helped his
people open their minds and hearts to
new possibilities actor Jay Baruchel
voices hiccup and his calm and boyish
tone fits his character like a glove he
didn't watch my movie for years because
of the name of fist really yes anyone
who meets Jay is impressed with how down
to earth he is which is what the cast of
How to Train Your Dragon adored about
him since Jay was used to acting in
front of the camera he had to get used
to getting into his characters mind not
his body while taking a peek behind the
scenes at the dream work studio this is
what Jay had to say about getting into
hiccup shoes I play a hiccup horrendous
haddock in the third to be a part of
something like this is a huge deal it's
just I haven't completely wrapped my
head around it although toothless might
not speak English he's taught hiccup
more about life and love than anyone
else while being interviewed at the
DreamWorks headquarters Jay went in
depth about what makes toothless and
hiccups relationships so special you
know they complete each other they're
both his outcasts they're both these
weird
you know toothless as far as we know the
only Night Fury there if there's one
thing hiccup excels at its giving
motivational speeches which is how he
convinced the Vikings to coexist with
dragons in the first place
for now it looks like hiccups got his
work cut out for him while his newest
enemy might be evil beyond belief were
confident that hiccup will do everything
he can to save his beloved dragons Olaf
er da Olufsen as Ragnar the rock little
is known about Ragnar The Rock except
for the fact that the big and mighty
Olaf er dari Olufsen is going to be
voicing him Ragnar is a new character in
the How to Train Your Dragon franchise
and he's going to be helping hiccup put
Grima behind bars
Olaf er is both an actor and a producer
and he's been a part of more productions
than you could imagine
he recently played the circus owner
skinned er in the fantastic beasts the
crimes of Grindelwald movie Olaf er also
had a part in the secret life of walter
mitty film however it was far from
impressionable
Duncan DreamWorks has done a fantastic
job at keeping all AFER's role
top-secret
however we suspect that he'll be a part
of the great battle between hiccup and
grimille although many of us aren't
familiar with this actor he's had his
hand in the cookie jar since the late
90s Ola for us recently breached the
voice-acting market which makes How to
Train Your Dragon the hidden world one
of his first major projects so during an
interview with Aaron stagers Olaf er
explains what he does to tackle any new
gig that comes his way the key to it is
just being very relaxed we don't know
about you but we can't wait to see what
Ragnar the rock has in store for us
Kristen Wiig as ruffnut Thorsten ruffnut
Thorsten might be a lady but she's more
of a Viking than anything she's tough as
nails and tends to punch first and ask
questions later she's a tomboy if we've
ever seen one and we couldn't imagine
her any other way
Kristen Wiig voices this character and
she brings her comedic side to life
ruffnut has a twin brother who she tends
to bump heads with
but I mean you could you can see that by
now we all know that Kristen is a
hilarious comedian who got her big break
by performing skits on Saturday Night
Live so it comes as no surprise to find
out that she improvises most of her
lines here's a funny movie moment that
was posted by the Cartoon Network okay
how about please don't kill me when it
comes to getting into character Kristen
is a champ the actress also plays Lucy
and Lucille Bluth in Despicable Me 2 her
voice is versatile and her accents
immaculate allowing her to play various
characters yeah what you just saw there
was a little something new I've been
working on it's a combination of jujitsu
we couldn't have asked for a better
person to voice the highly amusing
ruffnut Thorsten Jonah Hill as snotlout
jorgenson snotlout jorgenson isn't the
sharpest tool in the shed but he's a
classic viking if we've ever seen one he
loves the limelight which causes him to
embark on whatever journey comes his way
despite consider himself as a hero he
has trouble landing the girl of his
dreams due to how arrogant he can be
actor Jonah Hill voices snotlout and he
does him justice to say the least
much like Kristen Jonah Hill knows a
thing or two about improvisation which
is why many of his lines aren't scripted
here's what Dona had to say about his
character it's kind of a little bit of a
bully and he portrays himself as very
tough but deep down I think he's scared
during the same interview Jonah talks
about how challenging it was to get into
character despite having done some minor
voice acting for shows like The Simpsons
Jonah had never taken on a project of
such magnitude this is what the
acclaimed actor had to say about getting
into the groove of things you just try
and imagine yourself in whatever world
you can picture based on the scenes that
you're giving snotlout's been a
prominent character in all three of the
How to Train Your Dragon movies so it's
safe to say that Joan is more than
experienced by now by the time the
second movie came out Jonah's character
was doing everything he could to win
rough nuts affection during an interview
with movie extras Jonah explains why he
loved the second installment of the
franchise so much the dragons are so
cool they all
their own specific look and personality
and I thought that was just so clever
you guys think that ruffnut will see
snotlout in a different light
come How to Train Your Dragon 3 Gerard
Butler as stoic if there's one character
we all love and admire its stoic the
vast so imagine how surprised we were to
see him cast in the third How to Train
Your Dragon movie especially since he
sacrificed himself to save hiccup in the
last film while he's presumed as dead
we might be pleasantly surprised by his
revival however we're not holding our
breath because it's possible that he'll
simply be appearing in a flashback
Gerard Butler voices this epic character
and his Scottish accent makes him the
perfect guy for the job during an
interview with screen slam Gerard talked
about his character and how amazing he
truly was here's what the PS I Love You
actor had to say that's great there's
such great words for stoic y-you
wouldn't expect Gerard to be the voice
behind Stoics character but once you see
him in action
you can't imagine anyone else trying to
fill his boots this clip was posted by
movie clips coming soon and it shows
Gerard getting some great one-liners in
it's no secret that Gerard and crack are
great friends which is why we'd expect
their characters to be on the same boat
while interviewing with HitFix Gerard
came clean about which character he
would have enjoyed playing if he hadn't
been cast as stoic
although Gerard would have made a great
Gobber we're happy that he ended up
portraying stoic instead cate blanchett
as the volca were thought to believe
that hiccups mother died when he was
just a baby but how to train your dragon
to brought forth many surprises one of
them being that Valka was very much
alive in a dragon lover no less two-time
Oscar winner cate blanchett voices the
fiery volka and her gentle yet assertive
voice brings her character to life Kate
had done her research before auditioning
for Volkers role which he clearly states
during an interview that was posted by
the Dragon bassist YouTube channel and
having watched the first film then with
my children I went back and
several of the books Valka was
considered to be dead by her people and
this is because she was hauled away by a
dragon and never returned
however Valka had a secret love for
dragons one that she kept hidden from
anyone and everyone Kay portrays her
character in an optimistic light even
though she hasn't socialized with humans
in over a decade when it comes to
handling dragons volka son natural
retractable teeth and when it comes to
delivering a performance Kate's got it
in the bag which is why we are happy to
see that she'd be returning to the cast
for the film's third installment here's
a clip of Kate behind the scenes at the
DreamWorks to do a dragon broke into our
house finding you in the cradle I rushed
to protect you
Kate's Australian accent brings her one
step closer to sounding like a true born
Viking Kit Harington as eret last on the
list is eret son of eret this Viking is
complicated to say the least which is
why he often comes off as a cocky
mongrel instead of the sweetheart he is
although he might have a posed tick up
at first he quickly warms up to him and
joins his ranks Game of Thrones actor
Kit Harington voices this character and
his thick English accent does him
justice during an interview with HitFix
kick talked about the differences
between acting and voice acting and this
is what he had to say I've always found
hearing your own voice is the worst part
although kits usual characters might
come off as morose the actor is actually
super funny
here's a Universal Pictures audition
tape as proof it's nice to see toothless
being included in the fun when it comes
to giving motivational speeches
eret seems to have a golden tongue
however this is never stopped toothless
from mocking him behind his back here's
a clip of toothless making jabs at kids
character during the same
behind-the-scenes special and we must
continue to fight until before you go
make sure to let us know which character
you're most excited to see and how to
train your dragon the hidden world and
that's a wrap don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up thanks for
watching the things and see you next
time
[Music]